字幕: Arisa Kg
校正: Ayako Ezaki
皆さん
皆さんは本当においしい魚を食べたことがありますか
昨日の夕ご飯が魚だったよっていう方は
たくさんいるかもしれませんが
でも実は皆さんが食べている魚
本当の味を知らないかもしれませんよ
父親の実家は屋号を「伝左衛門屋」といいます
伝左衛門屋は
イカつり漁船を持ついわゆる網元でした
私が子供の頃には 朝になると
大漁旗をいっぱい立てたイカ釣り漁船が
たくさん入ってきて
大人には一升瓶の酒を
子供や家族にはお菓子を振る舞われ
とても楽しく賑やかで
まるでお祭りのようでした
また おばあさんと明け方５時くらいに
かごいっぱいのしらすをリアカーに乗せて
「しらすはよござんすかー」
と売り歩いたこともありました
その後 イカもあまり捕れなくなりましたので
私が就職で東京に来るころには
父親は３人の子供たちを育てるために
石積みの船に乗り
兼業の形で漁師は続けておりました
漁師で生計を立てていた頃は
必要な生活費には程遠く
下手すると一月収入がゼロということもありました
全く収入のない月があったりするもんですから
両親はしょっちゅう喧嘩をしていました
親のようにはなるまい
そう思って一生懸命勉強して
進学校に入ったんですけれども
進学する為の受験代も出してもらえることができず
なくなく就職することになりました
受験の費用も出してもらえない？
そんなこと信じられない
と思う方もいらっしゃるかもしれませんが
漁師って本当に稼ぐのが難しいんです
かごいっぱいの魚を市場に出しても
1000円 2000円は当たり前
時には 100円 200円
そういうこともざらなんです
さて１８の時 私は進学をあきらめて
就職のために上京しました
都会には田舎になかったファーストフードや
憧れのビフテキなど
魅力的なメニューがたくさんありましたので
しばらくそんな食生活が楽しくて
田舎の魚のことはすっかり忘れていました
１年後母方の伯父に入学金を貸してもらって
夜学のコンピューターの専門学校に入り
そこで知り合った主人がソフトハウスを
経営するということになりましたのと
私の妊娠をきっかけに
私も会社の経営に携わるようになりました
その後自分でも会社を立ち上げました
必死で働いたおかげで 生活にゆとりもできて
少しはぜいたくな食事ができるようになりました
でも魚は全然だめです
スーパーで買う魚はもちろんのこと
居酒屋の刺身も
ちょっとおしゃれな割烹なんかでも
魚は全然おいしくないんです
田舎に住んでいた頃は
三食刺身みたいな生活だったんで
もう魚はいいやなんて思っていたんですけれども
また美味しい魚を東京でも食べたい
と思うようになりました
父がとってきた魚を食べて
当たり前に感じていたその味は
実はなんでもありそうだったけど
都会にはなかったんです
イカの刺身が白かった時の衝撃
イカの刺身は透明だと思って育ちましたから
またあのイカを食べたいと思うと
何千円もするような
生きたイカを買うしかないんです
それから父がとってきて
ただでさんざん食いしていた
ウニやアワビ イクラやカニ
そんなものが手に入るような値段ではありません
その時やっと自分が特別な環境にいたんだな
ということに気づかされました
でもおかしいですよね
そんな贅沢なものをとっていた父が
何で貧乏だったんでしょうか
そんでもって
なんで田舎で食べていた魚は美味しいのに
東京では美味しくないのか
私はどうしても大槌の美味しい魚を
食べさせたいと思ったので
「三陸磯の味伝左衛門」
をオープンすることにしました
しかし お店はオープンしたものの
大槌の魚を東京で提供するのは難しかったんです
産直の魚などあまり扱ったことのない
都会の料理人にしたら
地元の魚なんて見た事のない
知らないような魚だったりするわけで
扱い方も料理の仕方も
分からないのだと思います
原価やメニューを任せられている料理長にしたら
そんなのもってのほかですよね
サイズがばらばらだったんだよ
たくさん来過ぎて原価圧迫してる
昨日頼んだけどしけで魚届かないじゃないか
そんな言い訳をされて
気付くといつも大槌からの魚は
仕入れられなくなっていました
それに「今日届いた魚そんなに新鮮じゃないよ」
と言われると何も言えません
地元の魚を地元と同じ鮮度で取り寄せないと
私の知っている本当の美味しい魚料理は
地元以外では提供できないんです
さて 漁師が魚を売る時は安い
買うときには高い
地元じゃ美味しいのに
都会ではあまり美味しくない
その理由は流通にあります
漁場でとれた魚は食卓に上がるまでに
たくさんの人が関わっています
その人たちがそれぞれ商売をするので
値段も上がりますし
時間も経ってしまうので
鮮度も落ちるわけです
では産直ならどうでしょう
そんな問題は一気に解決しますか
しかし最近こんな事件がありました
魚がいつ何が捕れるのか分からないんで
送った魚の伝票をFAXしてもらうように
なってるんですけど
17.5キロ 約3万円のマグロが届くというんです
大変な仕入れです
でもまあ明日はマグロ尽くし マグロ祭りだ
そう思って待ってましたら
届いてびっくりです
まず頭もしっぽもない
おおきなさくになってます
しかも発泡スチロールの氷が解けて
鶏肉のように真っ白になってるじゃないですか
これこそまさにシーチキンですよね
そもそもマグロは捨てるところがないんで
身だけになっていたら
17.5キロの価値は全然ないですし
白くなってたら刺身にもなりません
さすがに困って事情を説明したら
「そんなことあるはずがない
いいがかりだ」って怒ってしまって
「もう二度と魚は送らない」って言うんです
なぜこんなことになってしまったのか
皆さん 宅配便の温度問題をご存知ですよね
実はあれ以来 特にクール便での宅配は
サイズと重さが非常に厳しくなり
規格外は一切受け付けなくなってます
そのため大きなマグロを
そのまま送ることができず
しかもクール便で送れなかったので
氷が解けてしまった
そういうことになってしまった悲劇でした
お店を初めて十数年
そんな問題はちっとも解決しませんでした
そんなある時 取引先から
アイスクリームを７０時間一定の温度で
流通させることができる
高機能保冷剤を開発したよ
というお話がありました
保冷箱は再利用するのでとてもエコだと
しかもそれはクール便でなくて
普通便で問題なく送れるというのです
一般的な氷を入れた発泡での流通ですと
氷代 発泡スチロール代がかかりますし
クールで送るので郵送代も高いです
サイズの問題もありますし
全然融通が利きません
また魚は氷の温度0度になってしまうと
一気に鮮度が落ちてしまいます
また氷が解けて水になって
魚が浸ってしまったら
そういうことが度々あるということもあります
海の魚が真水に当たるんですから
美味しくなくなるのは当たり前なんです
私たちはその技術を使えば
魚を死後硬直させない温度で
新鮮なまま流通させることができる
今までの問題を解決するのではないか
と考えて 地元の大槌で
実証実験をすることになりました
私はこれはまさしく水産業の救世主だと思い
大手企業の力を借りながら
大槌町の町長をはじめ
役場の方や水産加工場の皆さまと
町おこしの企画を練り始めました
大槌の魚をブランド化したい
もっと広く知って食べてもらいたい
そんな打ち合わせをしている時に
あの東日本大震災が起きました
震災の状況については
皆さんご存知たと思うので
あえては語りませんが
自分が漁師の娘であったこと
上京してＩＴ企業を経営する事になって
その関係で取引先の技術で
震災前の町の復興に
関わることができていたという偶然
それは自分にとって 運命だと思いました
そうして完成した箱に復興の思いを込めて
「大槌復興絆便」と名付けました
この箱が大槌復興絆便です
そしてこれが大槌から届いた新鮮な魚です
新鮮でしょ
なんて写真を見ても分からないと思うので
昨日送った魚をお見せしたいと思います
これです どうでしょう
本当はもっと近くで見て頂けるといいんですけど
この箱はまさに動く冷蔵庫なんですね
なので新鮮な魚を送るだけじゃなくて
仕切ると大槌町のマツタケ
大槌マツタケも採れるんですけど
山菜だったりとか
岩手のブランド牛 ブランド肉
そんなものも一緒に送ることができます
魚のサイズに合わせれば
先ほど紹介したようなエピソード
サイズ問題とか温度問題も解決できるんです
しかも保冷材は氷と違って７０時間もありますから
今まで翌日に到着して
届けることしかできなかったエリア以外の
二日かかる遠方とかクールはない
海外などにも使うことができます
皆さん新巻鮭をご存知ですか
知ってる方
大槌は古くから南部鼻曲り鮭の産地で
今から400年前に江戸 今の東京に
このおいしい鮭をどうやって届けるのかと考えて
塩干しする加工方法を思いついたんです
実は大槌は 新巻鮭発祥の地なんです
こうやって大槌は栄えたということです
江戸時代には塩干しする加工方法で
２０世紀には氷で
そしてこれからは保冷剤で
このアイディアが大槌だけでなく
日本全国 いえ世界においても
漁業にイノベーションを
生み出すかもしれません
私はこれからも少しでも多くの方に
新鮮美味しい魚を知ってもらい
食べてもらえるように
流通のビジネスモデルを
作り続けたいと思います
皆さんがますます魚が好きになって
たくさん魚を買ってくれて
早くまた活気ある大槌漁港に戻りますように
皆さんにもう一度心から言いたいと思います
大槌のさがなはほんとにうんめーぞー
ありがとうございました